gun and walk into a public place
remember the remember like nobody
remembers the [ __ ] MIT dude the
weather shut up everything Korean guy oh
oh in DC airy it was in Virginia I think
yeah mighty Virginia yeah it is in
Virginia yeah I don't know [ __ ] about
anything outside of California but yeah
you know him - I think what he was like
bullied or some [ __ ] like that and then
his I mean this is not funny
but it was funny because he was taking a
bunch of pictures with him with a hammer
or [ __ ] yeah because he drew his power
from that weapon Polaroid and what did
he do he sent them to a news station yep
and they gave him all of the attention
that he wanted I was when I watched that
[ __ ] I started cracking up a little bit
not because the me situation was
terrible but is the fact that [ __ ] like
you took all these photos he's like I
don't like the lighting on this he's
like trying different like maybe if I
have a hair bow a little high I'm like
all serious and Emilee gun control and
dave is like he needed the light pick
him off the side putting like some
foundation on his face
oh my little kpop style you know but you
know that that's the funny thing they
like I think if a lot anybody who hasn't
been a bully before I pushed into a
corner they don't know why somebody
would do something like that
oh I know a lot of people this should
have gotten bullied is why you know it
kind of changes your perspective a lot
like this kid I don't know what the hell
he went through but he was an Asian
immigrant well I'm not sure he was in me
but he's the Asian kid in Virginia right
and you know yeah I'm saying yeah some
races why people probably made a few
jokes in a few a few hot thousands I
literally cannot like out of every
school I went to I think I remember one
Asian guy that's why I'm saying ya know
so he was like that oddball out and it
was probably hard for him to deal with
that [ __ ] yeah and the funny thing is
like you feel like when you push
somebody to a corner
not gonna do something if you see
animals and you push them to a corner no
matter how weak you you think that they
are yep they show their teeth absolutely
absolutely absolutely like at first you
like you could run up on a rabbit and at
first it'll like keep running away but
like I don't know
I'm [ __ ] my bite you particular
yeah they do it this is gonna go into
that [ __ ] weird reddit page all the
JK girls just do it real slow they look
into the camera and go I saw that uh
that [ __ ] reddit page once and that
[ __ ] is one of the funniest thing about
it is it's all TIFF it's it's literally
90% really oh my god it is like dude and
I was telling her about this [ __ ] too
because I'm like I'm didn't hear thing
of them like geo smoking hot Nikki
smoking hot
Julia smoking hot [ __ ] yes pretty hot
too but yeah the whole thing is Tiff's
big ol milkers like this you know
there's in the thing is is it like I
don't see it because I was like
scrolling through the [ __ ] because I
just found this like two weeks ago and I
was looking through it and I was like oh
that's picture TIFF oh this picture TIFF
but then I would notice row it's like
the table is flat but then these titties
like up over the table like what'd she
do what she's like dude I'm trying to be
on this reddit page
she's just dressed her titties on the
table it took me a minute to notice that
it was the breasteses it's also because
maybe it's because TIFF she also posted
the most out of everybody I think she's
a bad [ __ ] like it's what I can't see
her like that because I met her was you
super young Tim's a bad [ __ ] though she
got a good face big old titties she
young she fine she out here TIFF is 30
now which blows my mind man really oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is 30 years old now man
yeah dude I I googled how old you were
before I came here
yeah man 32 yeah Wow
good that crazy crazy David no I'm still
I'm still I'm actually turning baby
ma'am I yeah I have 32 yeah yeah
it's about that age miss me all the time
how'd my [ __ ] back went out yesterday
[ __ ] goddamnit I'm old now man I like
this age though I think when I think
when I was younger I used to think
thirty was super old mmm-hmm but then if
I if somebody asked me right now like
hey Kent you wouldn't you don't you wish
you could go back in time and be young
and be like nah because it took me a
while to be comfortable in my own skin
and that that happened through time yeah
I can't go through that anxiety again Oh
actually I can't do that [ __ ] I can't go
through second-guessing every single
step that I make I'm at a point in my
life where I'm I still second-guess a
lot but it's nowhere near how it used to
be because I'm more solid right now my
foundation is strong it's like what I
say [ __ ] you now I mean it it's crazy
it's for my spirit because you know
you're like I don't need you I have a
plan here's my five-year plan and I
don't see you in this go [ __ ] yourself
yeah it feels [ __ ] good like I could
save my opinions without worrying too
much about the repercussions because I
just don't give up
[ __ ] yeah you know because before it was
like this is like something small so you
know let's say you had a group of
friends right and this is some [ __ ] that
always happens in high school and you
know if you're in high school and you're
like this you know this you know what's
up you have a group of like let's say 10
friends right but you know the 10
friends in high school yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah but you're like 10
friends right and there's probably let's
say eight of them you really like but
two of them you really don't [ __ ] with
okay right
but with those two that you don't [ __ ]
with because you're so worried about
what the perception of the group and
then you know keep anything is cool you
just you keep you're always nice to them
and you always invite them out well
guess what kids when you move past 18
and you're like in your 30s those two
people are never invited to cookout ever
because you don't have to be around
people you don't want to be around in
high school because you have to go to
this thing called school you have to be
around them 24/7 so you have to look at
their face hear their voice when you're
an adult that you couldn't create your
own situations you can choose who you
want to be around that is what I love
about being an adult it's like look at
look at this I don't like you don't come
near me I will [ __ ] in your food I will
literally [ __ ] in your food I will wait
for you to have a child just so like a
kidnapped your kid yeah you lost me at
10 friends can't
okay yeah I mean I watch it with my with
my high school friends till this day
really we've we've have we had the
sleeping off friends giving of course
and we've had it since we were 14 god
damn I never I just started always been
pretty quiet for me this whole time this
is the first year that like I've nonstop
had people hang out with and oh my god
David I'm going home for the first time
this year in three years and like yeah
dude and my schedule is like jam-packed
like there's because okay I'm I am like
undoubtedly like at least for maybe like
my three years of high school like those
that span of grades I'm definitely the
like I don't like probably I don't to
say most more successful but more kind
of popular like outward facing thing
because like I have the following like I
do you know [ __ ] like this I'm out in LA
like a lot of people are still back at
home and so it's really funny that all
of these people that really [ __ ] on me
growing up like really [ __ ] on me
like now there's kind of like I don't
see like a buzz about me like back home
because it's a really really small town
but like suddenly people that didn't
want anything to do with me I'm so proud
of you [ __ ] years ago they're like
I'm so proud of you I always knew you're
gonna make it yo man you're doing great
big do you get that all the time oh my
god Nate it may never they never wanted
to do guys work your ass off work your
ass off the flex it feels good to suck
your [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know what
okay suck your [ __ ] I like that phrase
because it's like suck my dick but the
reason it's so funny because when people
do do that like I've there are people
who have literally reached out to me
they go yo man high school was a trip
right look at that I'm like who the [ __ ]
are you like I don't even know you dude
I had a there was a guy that sat behind
me in social studies for like because
our last names were similar for like
years we never really spoke one day he
followed me on Instagram and I was like
oh I'll follow him back and then he just
starts responding to every story and I'm
like we literally never spoke and high
school is a trip right what
[ __ ] you talk with me yo either this
was a while ago but somebody Sacramento
is not that big of a town and if you if
you if you say some [ __ ] people probably
here that's why I want to tell stories
from back in Sacramento I don't use the
actual names right because it's a small
town you know word gets around like that
but this guy was going around I don't
even know this dude like I kind of
remember his face for maybe like a year
but or maybe I seen him on school or
something around school [ __ ] but he was
saying some [ __ ] like oh like David's
like [ __ ] persona that he puts online
that's some new [ __ ] he was never like
that in high school and I'm like
thinking like you don't even know me how
would you know this how would you
[ __ ] know this you never had a
conversation with me you never gave me
the time of day yeah you know what I
mean like it's like you never ever
[ __ ] talk to me I've been the same
dude since [ __ ] day one you know all
my friends know this [ __ ] you know I've
probably gotten a lot louder since I got
an older because I gave less [ __ ] other
than that it's been the same [ __ ] guy
I mean you could ask any of my friends
from back at home but this random person
who doesn't know me he wants to gain a
little bit of attention and fame by
talking [ __ ] about me to other people
around my thing and the funny thing is
I'm not a non-confrontational person so
you know and I had to do this a couple
of times with people and not to say like
I wasn't a fighter throw down I'm not
gonna I'm not confrontational touch a
fist fighting but if you have a problem
we should be able to talk about it so I
was at a it's not called Vaughn's it's
called Safeway you know back in a NorCal
so I was at a Safeway so this dude kind
of looks he's kind of like you know
doing that [ __ ] di thing like oh like
whether he should approach me or not oh
you know you're one of those things
right probably like he wonders like does
he know does he know I've been talking
[ __ ] yeah and so like I just got like
what's up bro he's like it what's up man
how you doing dude it's like you'd been
doing big things already my blood
pressure is starting to rise I was like
that's cool man I was like hey bro like
I don't even know you like that but how
come you like tell all these other
people that like I'm not who I am he's
like nah now you getting [ __ ] twisted
man that's not what I said I'm like what
is going on with this dude right this is
like this [ __ ] maintenance and people
like if you're gonna talk that [ __ ] at
least own up to it my thing is like if I
talk [ __ ] behind your back I was believe
I resent to your face yes that's exactly
I was gonna say like it's not even like
oh if I talk [ __ ] about you you can
approach me and we'll like hash it out
like no I've already said it to you yeah
in fact I make sure that I say it to you
before I go say it to anybody else and
if you know if I'm saying it [ __ ] you
like seriously I and I have no problem
if if I get to a point where I'm talking
about somebody to somebody else it means
I've exhausted all resources solving the
problem with the person yeah and I'm
done with it I'm vet I'm venting I'm fed
up
like I don't talk [ __ ] to talk [ __ ] if
I'm talking [ __ ] it's probably to vent
but it's because you [ __ ] pissed me
off we've been trying to work this out
it's not working out I've told you to go
[ __ ] yourself and here we are well how
is that talking [ __ ] behind your back
I've already said it to the front of
your face exactly what is it we're just
not adding anything negative yeah we
just can't say anything negative like no
I don't like you yeah that's okay that's
okay like if you don't if we don't I
feel like I'm talking like you know what
if I don't like you and I'm talking [ __ ]
about you talk [ __ ] back to me that's
just unless just headshot we're like
great we don't like each other at least
robbing fun I get to yell at you you get
to give me constructive feedback it's
funny too cuz there's some other people
like I talking mad [ __ ] about certain
people like that I'd really don't like
and it is it's very rare that I actually
dislike somebody right so like you just
like to make this like them a lot but
the funny thing is is like I hear things
that they've said about me which doesn't
really affect me I'm just more like damn
like you know light like that that's
cool right it's like I never liked you
too but you're going out of your way to
talk that [ __ ] but the funny thing is
they forget you talk [ __ ] I could talk
[ __ ] way better than you so let's let's
get let's do this [ __ ] right so if she
gets a little out of hand and then all
sudden I receive a message through
somebody else because they can't
confront me they tell one of our mutual
friends you know just tell David it's
all love man there's all good oh now I'm
just gonna do it more times more you you
you [ __ ] up